Ce dont je voudrais parler fait vraiment partie des plus grandes problématiques mondiales.
Je ne vais pas parler de mon livre « L’Ecologiste sceptique » --
ça vaut mieux probablement.
(Rires)
Mais je vais vous parler de : quels sont les grands problèmes du monde ?
Et franchement, avant de continuer, je devrais demander à chacun d’entre vous
d’essayer et de sortir un papier et un crayon
parce qu’en fait je vais vous demander de m’aider à voir comment on va faire ça.
Donc sortez votre papier et votre crayon.
La vérité c’est qu’il y a énormément de problèmes là-bas dehors, dans le monde.
Je vais juste en lister quelques-uns.
Il y a 800 millions de personnes qui meurent de faim.
Il y a un milliard de personnes sans eau potable.
2 milliards de personnes sans assainissement.
Il y a plusieurs millions qui sont en train de mourir du Sida.
Et la liste continue encore et encore.
Il y a 2 milliards de personnes qui seront durement touchées par le changement climatique, etc.
Il y a beaucoup, beaucoup de problèmes là-bas dehors.
Dans un monde idéal, nous les résoudrions tous, mais nous ne le faisons pas.
En réalité nous ne résolvons pas tous les problèmes.
Et si nous ne le faisons pas, la question, je pense, que nous devons nous poser --
et la raison pour laquelle tout ceci est dans la session économie – revient à dire,
si nous ne faisons pas tout, nous devons vraiment commencer par nous demander,
lesquels devrions-nous résoudre en premier ?
Et c’est la question que j’aimerais vous poser.
Sinon nous avions, disons 50 milliards de dollars à dépenser sur les 4 prochaines années
pour faire évoluer le monde dans le bon sens, où devrions nous commencer ?
Nous avons identifié 10 des plus grands défis dans le monde,
et je vais vous brièvement vous les lire.
Le changement climatique, les maladies contagieuses, les conflits, l’éducation,
la volatilité financière, la gouvernance et la corruption,
la malnutrition et la faim, les mouvements migratoires,
l’eau et l’assainissement, et les subventions et les barrières commerciales.
Nous pensons que cette liste, de bien des manières,
couvre les plus grandes problématiques mondiales.
La question évidente à poser serait,
lesquelles pensez-vous être les plus importantes ?
Par où commencer pour résoudre ces problèmes ?
Mais c’est une mauvaise approche du problème.
C’est ce qui en fait a été posé à Davos en janvier.
Mais bien sûr, le fait même de demander aux gens de se pencher sur ces problèmes est tout aussi problématique.
Parce que nous ne pouvons pas résoudre les problèmes.
Pour sûr le plus gros problème que nous ayons dans le monde est que nous allons tous mourir un jour.
Mais nous n’avons la technologie pour résoudre ça, n’est-ce pas ?
Donc le but n’est pas de mettre des priorités aux problèmes,
le but en revanche est de mettre des priorités sur les solutions aux problèmes.
Et cela donnerait par exemple -- bien sûr cela devient un peu plus compliqué.
Pour le changement climatique, ça serait le protocole de Kyoto.
Pour les maladies contagieuses, ça serait des centres de soins et des moustiquaires.
Pour les conflits, ça serait des troupes de maintien de la paix de l’ONU, etc.
Ce que je voudrais vous demander d’essayer de faire,
c’est en gros en 30 secondes -- et je sais que ça paraît
mission impossible -- d’écrire ce que vous pensez
être probablement au sommet de la liste des priorités.
Et aussi -- et c’est là, bien sûr, que les considérations économiques sont diabolisantes --
écrivez les choses que nous ne devrions pas faire, en tout cas pas en premier.
Qu’est-ce qui devrait être au bas de la liste ?
S’il vous plaît, prenez 30 secondes, discutez avec votre voisin si vous voulez,
et essayez juste de vous fixer sur ce qui devrait être nos priorités principales
et ce qui est en bas de la liste des priorités des solutions que nous avons
pour résoudre les plus grands problèmes du monde.
La partie stupéfiante de ce processus -- et bien sûr, je veux dire,
j’aimerais le faire -- je n’ai que 18 minutes,
je vous ai déjà donné un sacré bout de mon temps, non ?
J’aimerais vraiment le décortiquer, et vous faire réfléchir sur ce processus,
et c’est en fait ce que nous avons fait.
Et je vous encourage donc vivement,
et je suis sûr que nous aurons aussi ces discussions par la suite,
à réfléchir à la façon donc nous donnons vraiment des priorités aux choses.
Bien sûr, vous devez vous demander,
mais pourquoi donc une liste comme ça n’a jamais été faite auparavant ?
Et une des raisons c’est que fixer des priorités est incroyablement désagréable.
Personne ne veut le faire.
Bien sûr, chaque organisation adorerait être en haut d’une telle liste.
Mais chaque organisation détesterait tout autant ne pas être en haut de la liste.
Et puisqu’il y a beaucoup plus de non « premiers-sur-la-liste »
que de premiers sur la liste, c’est tout à faire logique
de ne pas vouloir établir une telle liste.
Nous avons l’ONU depuis presque 60 ans,
et pourtant nous n’avons jamais fait une liste fondamentale
de toutes les grandes choses que nous pouvons faire dans le monde,
et une fois faite, de celles à faire en premier.
Donc cela ne signifie pas que nous ne donnons pas de priorité --
toute décision implique une priorisation,
même implicitement -- mais il y a peu de chances que le résultat soit aussi bon
que si nous effectuons réellement un processus pour mettre des priorités,
et que ce processus soit explicite et sujet à débat.
Donc ce que je dis c’est que nous avons,
depuis très longtemps, eu ce problème quand il s’agit de faire des choix.
Il y a beaucoup, beaucoup de choses que nous pouvons faire là-dehors,
mais nous ne connaissons pas leurs coûts, leur échelle.
Nous n’en avons pas la moindre idée.
Imaginez-vous aller dans un restaurant et voir cet épais menu,
mais n’avoir aucune idée des prix.
Vous voyez le genre, vous avez une pizza, mais vous n’avez aucune idée de combien elle coûte.
Elle pourrait être à 1$, elle pourrait être à 1000$.
Ca pourrait être une pizza taille familiale.
Ca pourrait très bien être une part individuelle, vous voyez ?
Nous aimerions savoir ce genre de choses.
Et c’est précisément ce que le Consensus de Copenhague essaie de faire --
mettre un prix sur ces éléments.
Donc en gros, il y a eu ce processus du Consensus de Copenhague.
Nous avons pris 30 des meilleurs économistes mondiaux, 3 pour chaque domaine.
Donc nous avons mis 3 des meilleurs économistes mondiaux sur la question du changement climatique.
Que pouvons-nous faire ? Quel en sera le coût ?
Et quel en serait le bénéfice ?
Même chose pour les maladies contagieuses.
3 des meilleurs experts mondiaux expliquant ce que nous pouvons faire.
Quel en serait le prix ?
Que devrions-nous faire à ce sujet, quels seraient les effets ?
Et ainsi de suite.
Ensuite nous avons demandé à certains des meilleurs économistes mondiaux,
8 des meilleurs économistes mondiaux, dont 3 Prix Nobel,
de se réunir à Copenhague en mai 2004.
Nous les avons appelés la dream team.
Leurs pairs de l’Université de Cambridge ont décidé de les appeler
le Real Madrid des économistes.
Ca marche très bien en Europe, mais ça ne fonctionne pas vraiment ici.
Et concrètement ils sont arrivés à une liste de priorités.
Et alors la question surgit, pourquoi donc des économistes ?
Et bien sûr, ça me fait très plaisir que vous posiez la question -- (Rire) --
parce que c’est une très bonne question.
Je veux dire, normalement, si vous voulez apprendre quelque chose sur le paludisme,
vous demandez à un expert de la question du paludisme.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus sur le climat, vous demandez à un climatologue.
Mais si vous voulez savoir auquel de ces problèmes vous devez vous affairer en premier,
vous ne pouvez demander à aucun des 2, parce que ça n’est pas leur rôle.
C’est ce que font les économistes.
Ils fixent des priorités.
Ils ont cette tâche ingrate de dire ce que nous devrions faire en premier lieu,
puis ce que nous devrions faire ensuite seulement.
Donc voici la liste, et j’aimerais la partager avec vous.
Bien sûr, vous pouvez aussi jeter un oeil au site internet,
et nous pouvons en parler plus, j’en suis sûr, au cours de la journée.
En gros ils sont arrivés à cette liste finale où ils expliquent
qu’il y a des projets pas terribles -- dit simplement, des projets
où lorsque vous investissez un dollar, vous avez moins d’un dollar en retour.
Ensuite vous avez les projets corrects, les bons projets et les très bons projets.
Et bien sûr, c’est avec les très bons projets que nous devrions commencer.
Je vais commencer par la fin de la liste
pour qu’on finisse en parlant des meilleurs projets.
Ceux-ci sont les mauvais projets.
Comme vous pouvez le constater au bas la liste nous trouvons le changement climatique.
Cela choque beaucoup de monde, et c’est probablement une des raisons
pour lesquelles les gens me diront de ne pas revenir.
Et j’aimerais parler de ça, parce que c’est vraiment étonnant.
Pourquoi donc en est-il ainsi ?
Et je vais essayer d’y revenir
parce que c’est probablement un des points
de désaccord avec la liste que vous avez écrite tout à l’heure.
La raison pour laquelle ils en sont venus à dire que le protocole de Kyoto --
ou quelque chose qui irait plus loin que Kyoto -- est un mauvais coup
est simplement parce que c’est très peu efficient.
Ça ne dit pas que le changement climatique n’existe pas.
Ça ne dit pas que ce n’est pas un problème important.
Mais cela dit en revanche que ce que nous pouvons faire
est minime, et à un coût très élevé.
Ce que nous montre la moyenne de tous les modèles macro-économiques,
c’est que le protocole de Kyoto, si tout le monde se mettait d’accord, coûterait environ 150 milliards de dollars par an.
Ça représente énormément d’argent.
Ça représente 2 à 3 fois l’aide au développement
distribuée au Tiers-Monde tous les ans.
Et pourtant cela n’améliorerait pas grand chose.
Tous les modèles s’accordent à dire que cela ne repousserait que de 6 ans le réchauffement à échéance 2100.
Donc le type au Bengladesh qui sera inondé en 2100 aura un sursis jusqu’en 2106.
Ce qui est un peu mieux, mais pas beaucoup beaucoup mieux.
Donc l’idée est de dire, bien, nous avons dépensé beaucoup d’argent pour ne pas faire tant de bien que ça.
Et juste pour vous donner un ordre de grandeur,
l’ONU estime qu’en fait la moitié de ce montant,
donc environ 75 milliards de dollar par an,
apporterait une solutions à la majorité des problèmes de base dans le monde.
Nous pourrions donner une eau potable, l’assainissement, les soins médicaux de base
et une éducation à chaque être humain sur Terre.
Donc nous devons nous poser la question, voulons-nous dépenser 2 fois plus
pour faire si peu ?
Ou bien la moitié de la somme ne suffirait-elle pas pour faire un bien formidable ?
Et voilà pourquoi ça devient un mauvais projet.
Ça ne veut pas dire que si avions tout l’argent possible à disposition, nous ne le ferions pas.
Mais ça veut dire que lorsque nous ne le faisons pas, c’est juste parce que ce n’est pas notre priorité première.
Les projets corrects -- bon je ne vais pas tous les commenter --
mais les maladies contagieuses, les soins médicaux de base -- ne sont que là,
simplement parce que, effectivement, les services médicaux de base sont une chose formidable.
Cela fait beaucoup de bien, mais c’est aussi très, très cher.
À nouveau, cela nous ramène soudainement
à repenser aux 2 aspects de l’équation.
Si nous regardons les bons projets, beaucoup de projets d’eau et d’assainissement y apparaissent.
Encore une fois, l’eau et l’assainissement sont super importants,
mais beaucoup d’infrastructure c’est coûteux.
Donc j’aimerais vous montrer les 4 priorités principales
qui devraient au moins être parmi les premières que nous traitions
lorsque nous parlons de la manière de traiter les problèmes dans le monde.
Le 4ème meilleur sujet est celui du paludisme -- en finir avec le paludisme.
L’impact du paludisme est d’environ 2 milliards de nouveaux cas par an.
Cela pourrait même avoir des répercussions en terme de PIB
chaque année pour les nations touchées.
Si nous investissons environ 13 milliards de dollars sur les 4 prochaines années,
nous pourrions diminuer de moitié cet impact.
Nous pourrions éviter 500 000 décès.
mais peut-être encore plus important, nous pourrions éviter à un milliard de personnes
d’être infectées chaque année.
Nous pourrions accroître de manière significative leur capacité
à se pencher sur les nombreux autres problèmes auxquels ils doivent faire face.
Bien sûr aussi, sur le long terme, s’adapter au changement climatique.
Le 3ème meilleur est le libre-échange.
En gros, le modèle a montré que si nous pouvions mettre en place le libre-échange,
et en particulier diminuer les subventions aux États-Unis et en Europe,
nous pourrions faire progresser l’économie globale
vers ce chiffre assourdissant de 2400 milliards de dollars par an,
dont la moitié au bénéfice du Tiers-Monde.
Encore une fois, cela revient à dire que nous pourrions en réalité sortir
Encore une fois, cela revient à dire que nous pourrions en réalité sortir 200 à 300 millions de personnes de la pauvreté,
véritablement rapidement, en 2 à 5 ans.
Ça serait la 3ième meilleure chose que nous puissions faire.
La seconde serait de se pencher sur la malnutrition.
Pas seulement sur la malnutrition en général, en revanche il y a un moyen très peu coûteux
de régler le problème de la malnutrition, à savoir, les carences en vitamines et minéraux.
Dit simplement, environ la moitié de la population mondiale manque
de fer, de zinc, d’iode et de vitamine A.
Si nous investissons environ 12 milliards de dollars,
nous pourrions faire une grande avancée sur cette problématique.
C’est le 2ième meilleur investissement que nous puissions faire.
Et le meilleur serait de se concentrer sur le Sida.
En gros, si nous investissons 27 milliards de dollars sur les 8 prochaines années,
nous pourrions éviter 28 millions de cas de Sida.
À nouveau, ce que ça fait et ce que ça signifie est
qu’il y a deux façons de traiter le problème du Sida.
L’un est le traitement, l’autre est la prévention.
Et à nouveau, dans un monde idéal, nous ferions les deux.
Mais dans un monde où nous ne faisons ni l’un ni l’autre, ou bien où nous ne le faisons pas bien,
nous devons au moins nous poser la question d’où nous devrions investir en premier.
Et le traitement est beaucoup, beaucoup plus cher que la prévention.
Donc en fait, ce que ça dit c’est que nous pouvons faire beaucoup plus
en investissant sur la prévention.
En gros pour une dépense donnée,
nous pouvons avoir un impact donné grâce au traitement,
et un impact 10 fois plus grand si on se concentre sur la prévention.
Donc encore une fois, nous nous concentrons sur la prévention plutôt que sur le traitement,
en premier lieu.
Ce que cela permet en réalité, c’est de nous faire réfléchir à nos priorités.
J’aimerais que vous jetiez un oeil à votre liste de priorités et vous demandiez,
avais-je raison de la faire ainsi ?
Ou bien êtes-vous arrivés à quelque chose de similaire à notre résultat ?
Bon, bien sûr, encore une fois il y a la question du changement climatique.
Je vois beaucoup de gens qui trouvent très très improbable que nous procédions ainsi.
Nous devrions aussi nous pencher sur le changement climatique,
si ce n’est pour une autre raison que celle de la taille du problème.
Mais bien sûr, nous ne traitons pas tous les problèmes.
Il y a beaucoup de problèmes là-bas dehors dans le monde.
Et ce dont je veux m’assurer c’est que, si nous nous attelons vraiment à leur résolution,
alors que nous nous concentrions sur les bons.
Ceux pour lesquels nous pouvons faire beaucoup de bien au lieu d’un petit peu.
Et je pense en fait -- Thomas Schelling,
un des membres de la dream team, il le dit très, très bien.
Une chose que les gens ont tendance à oublier, c’est que dans 100 ans,
lorsque les impacts du changement climatique dont nous parlons se feront sentir,
les gens seront beaucoup, beaucoup plus riches.
Même dans les scenarios les plus pessimistes de l’ONU,
on estime que l’habitant moyen du monde en développement en 2100
sera aussi riche que nous le sommes aujourd’hui.
Beaucoup plus probablement il sera 2 à 4 fois plus riche que nous ne le sommes aujourd’hui.
Et bien sûr, nous serons encore plus riches que ça.
Mais la chose à comprendre, lorsqu’on parle de sauver des gens,
ou d’aider les gens au Bengladesh en 2100,
nous ne parlons pas d’un Bengladi pauvre.
Nous parlons en fait d’un néerlandais plutôt riche.
Et donc le but de tout ça, bien sûr, c’est de dire,
voulons-nous dépenser beaucoup d’argent pour aider, un peu,
dans 100 ans, un néerlandais plutôt riche ?
Ou bien voulons-nous venir en aide aux personnes vraiment pauvres, en ce moment, au Bengladesh,
qui ont vraiment besoin de cette aide, et que nous pouvons aider à vraiment moindre coût ?
Ou, comme le dit Schelling, imaginez-vous riche -- comme vous le serez --
un riche chinois, un riche bolivien, un riche congolais, en 2100
repensant à 2005, et disant, “C’est tellement étrange que vous vous soyez tant soucié
de m’aider un peu à m’adapter au changement climatique,
et que vous ayez pris aussi peu soin d’aider mon grand-père
et mon arrière grand-père, que vous auriez pu aider tellement plus,
et qui avaient beaucoup plus besoin d’aide.”
Donc je pense que ça nous indique réellement pourquoi
nous devons clairement fixer nos priorités.
Même si cela n’est pas en accord avec la façon dont nous abordons le problème habituellement.
Bien sûr, c’est principalement dû au fait que le changement climatique a si bonne image.
Nous avons, vous voyez, “Le Jour d’Après” -- ça rend bien, hein ?
C’est un bon film dans le sens où
je veux certainement le voir, mais je ne m’attends pas à ce que Emmerich
fasse jouer Brad Pitt dans son prochain film
creusant des latrines en Tanzanie ou quelque chose comme ça. (Rire)
Ça ne fait pas un film.
Donc, de bien des façons, je vois le Consensus de Copenhague
et tout le débat sur les priorités
comme une bonne argumentation en faveur des problèmes ennuyeux.
Pour être sûr qu’il ne s’agit pas de nous faire nous sentir bien,
il ne s’agit pas de faire que les choses reçoivent plus d’attention médiatiques que les autres,
mais il s’agit de leur attribuer chacune une place pour que nous puissions réellement faire le plus de bien.
Les autres objections, je pense, qui sont importantes à signaler,
sont que d’une certain façon je -- ou plutôt nous -- pose un faux choix.
Bien sûr, nous devrions tout faire,
dans un monde idéal -- je serais tout à fait d’accord.
Je pense que nous devrions tout faire, mais nous ne le faisons pas.
En 1970, les pays développés ont décidé que nous allions dépenser
2 fois plus aujourd’hui qu’en 1970 pour le monde en développement.
Depuis, notre aide s’est réduite de moitié.
Donc nous n’avons pas trop l’air de nous diriger
vers une résolution rapide des grands problèmes.
De manière semblable, les gens disent aussi, mais qu’en est-il de la guerre en Irak ?
Vous savez, nous dépensons 100 milliards de dollars.
Pourquoi ne pas utiliser cet argent pour faire le bien dans le monde ?
Je suis tout à fait pour.
Si l’un d’entre vous peut convaincre Bush de faire ça, ça serait parfait.
Mais l’idée bien sûr, reste de dire que,
si on obtient 100 autres milliards de dollars,
nous voulons toujours les dépenser de la meilleure façon possible, n’est-ce pas ?
Donc la vraie problématique ici, c’est de nous affairer à nouveau
à définir les bonnes priorités.
Je devrais évoquer ça brièvement, avons-nous réellement la bonne liste ?
Vous savez, quand vous demandez aux meilleurs économistes mondiaux,
vous finissez inévitablement par poser la question à des vieux américains blancs.
Et ils ne sont pas nécessairement, vous savez,
la meilleure façon de voir le monde dans sa totalité.
Donc nous avons en fait demandé à 80 jeunes gens du monde entier
de venir et de résoudre le même problème.
Les 2 seuls pré-requis étaient qu’ils soient étudiants à l’université,
et qu’ils parlent anglais.
La majorité d’entre eux étaient, en premier lieu, issus de pays en développement.
Ils avaient les mêmes informations mais ils pouvaient déborder largement
du périmètre de la discussion, et ils l’ont sûrement fait,
pour aboutir à leurs propres listes.
Et la chose surprenante était que cette liste était très similaire --
avec la malnutrition et les maladies en haut de la liste
et le changement climatique en bas de la liste.
Nous l’avons refait de nombreuses fois.
Il y a eu bien d’autres séminaires, bien d’autres étudiants, bien d’autres choses.
Tous ont aboutis à grosso modo la même liste.
Et cela me donne bon espoir, vraiment, de dire que je crois
qu’une voie s’ouvre pour nous amener à penser en termes de priorités.
Et de se poser la question : qu’est-ce qui est le plus important dans le monde ?
Bien sûr, dans un monde idéal, à nouveau, nous aimerions tout faire.
Mais si nous ne le faisons pas, alors nous devons commencer à penser à où nous devrions commencer.
Je vois le Consensus de Copenhague comme un processus.
Nous l’avons fait en 2004,
et nous espérons réunir encore plus de monde,
obtenir de l’information de bien meilleure qualité pour 2008, 2012.
Trouver la bonne voie pour le monde.
Mais aussi comment penser aux choix politiques.
Commencer à dire, “ Faisons
non pas ce qui fait peu et coûte très cher,
non pas ce que nous ne savons pas faire,
mais faisons ces super choses qui peuvent faire
un bien fou, à un coût dérisoire, tout de suite.
Au final, on peut ne pas être d’accord
dans le débat sur la façon dont sont fixées les priorités,
mails il faut être honnête et franc en disant que
s’il y a des choses que l’on fait, il y en a aussi que l’on ne fait pas.
Si nous nous préoccupons trop de certaines choses,
nous finissons par ne plus nous préoccuper de certaines autres choses.
Donc j’espère que ceci nous aidera à fixer des priorités,
et à penser à comment nous pouvons mieux œuvrer pour le monde.
Merci.